Whether you're a believer or a skeptic, you
have to admit that Ghost Adventures is pretty
darn entertaining. Yet, there's more to this
series than just investigating creepy, abandoned
areas with extensive paranormal histories.
So let's investigate the untold truths behind
Zak's spooky collectible
Whether you love or hate Zak "the Ghost Bro"
Bagans' style, he puts his money where his
paranormal-loving mouth is, whether cameras
are rolling or not. In August 2015, Bagans
plunked down $32,000 for a van that belonged
to Dr. Jack Kevorkian, who notoriously assisted
with the suicides of 130 confirmed patients.
Bagans says that he doesn't plan on using
the vehicle for Ghost Adventures, but he does
intend on investigating the van. He told The
New York Daily News:
"I want to have it to show recognition to
these people and the energy they had at the
time of their death. I can't wait to get it
and see what I feel off of it…It called
out to me."
That's one heck of a collectible, bro.
The macabre extends to their real lives
Reality can be a lot scarier than any haunted
house. Paranormal investigators Mark and Debbie
Constantino were featured on Ghost Adventures,
and now may be featured posthumously on a
true crime series. KRNV-TV reports that the
couple had a long, dark history of domestic
violence. That history came to a tragic head
in September 2015, when Mark killed Debbie,
as well as himself, after an extensive SWAT
team lockdown.
Too scary, even for them
Bagans purchased a Gary, Indiana home in 2014
after reports that the family living within
it were terrorized by demons. These reports
were backed up by claims from child protective
services, who also witnessed the creepy activity.
Problem was, the house was actually too scary,
even for Bagans. TMZ reports that while filming
a documentary in the home, Bagans felt "dark
energy" and claimed "the demons were the real
deal." Bagans tried exorcising the house but
said his attempts failed. Believing the house
was actually a portal to Hell, Bagans paid
to have the house demolished in 2016, and
even had the rubble stored in a sealed facility
so no paranormal energy could escape from
it and affect anyone nearby. Phew.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube
channel to see more videos like the one you
just saw. And leave us a comment to tell us
what Ghost Adventures facts surprised you
the most...